当初呢
必看了三个指标
我们直接把它写出来的
第一个周转率
第二个年次量
第三筹码
这三个都要看
周转率年次量跟筹码
因为最近呢
周转率报告的股票都蛮好玩的
要嘛很好
要嘛很差
那我们来看一下
今日周转率高的股票
各位看一下
今天周转率高的股票呢
通常我盘中都会看年次量
年次年量
然后再看周转率
那周转率高的股票
你看今天的盟利
盟利周转率很高
今天是跟大红K
还没有涨停
胜幅到95%
那迅作也一样
今天周转率很高
所以你看到
这种周转率很高的
还有像红翼股啊
还有像豪敏
豪敏今天我有做到
它前天涨停
那周转率很高
那今天有拉高出货
後面再下殺
還有像成名店啊
哇這周轉率高
但是走勢是不怎麼樣
那波羅威之有提過
不曉得各位記不記得
波羅威呢有厲害的大咖
厲害大咖在這個位置買很多
這個你把它拉到60天你就會看到了
厲害大咖
波羅安安爾跟原物成中
這兩個蠻厲害的
像兆風新主
都是厲害的大咖
厲害大咖有在吃這一檔
這檔真的蠻不錯的
这个位置应该不是短线的高点
我觉得它不是短线高点
新闻又有讲
航海王也持有这一档
变第一大股东
前天晚上看周转率隔天要空吗
不是
不是这样
周转率呢
它是盘中会有的指标
你前天看的个股
它隔天不一定要空
我举例来说
有些股票前天可能周转率很高
可是当天呢
一开盘没什么量
那代表说隔中可能还没出货隔中可能还没出货那就不一定能空所以周转率呢我们会搭配筹码一起看周转率跟筹码还有昨日涨跌幅会一起看
那假如昨天涨跌幅呢
没有很好的
那可能今天就不错
昨天涨跌幅小涨小跌
可能今天不错
那昨天涨跌幅呢
假如是涨停的
那我们今天呢
盘中我们要好好研究筹码
看人家到底是在出货
还是在进货
那这个廉次量呢
就是我们在买盘爆量
买盘捷径的时候
我们会去看一些东西
但那种比较细节的东西
我还是留在课堂上在讲
我们不能在这里全部把它讲完
你不能说每次看到买盘捷径你就空
不行
你还要再去研究一下
第一个人研究一下筹码
因为有时候买盘捷径
只是一个攻击的宗旨而已
它今天就是要一路往北攻
一路向北
然后买盘捷径稍微休息一下
像这种它在筹码看得出来
它在挂单上看得出来
挂单上跟在筹码中看得出来
那筹码我们就要看
他最近买进的人
像昨天买的人
例如说我最近做液态
那只会买的人呢
他到底是隔日冲呢
还是波段课
所以我们要知道
像这原大台都买很多吧
隔日冲
隔天冲掉
那你看这个隔日冲
其实今天的黑K就觉得比较猜得到
通常我们每次看到黑K
好像都有人去追
我来看一下今天谁追
哇今天原大台中好厉害啊
我说他很厉害的是
他居然可以这样子
把他出掉4000多张
那买的人都只有100多张
太省了
购买软体会有连次量收入
对
又每真小编的语音当中赔钱也算
有这样子
所以呢
筹码很重要
连次量很重要
然后呢
周转率也很重要
这三个都很重要
你只要看这三个啦
其实我盘中我就是看这三个
周转率连次量跟筹码
那周转率突然报告的
那卖盘捷径我可能会早约束